نشرت وسائل اعلام روسيا مشاهدا من تصعد
اعمده الدخان في محطه للحاويات في مدينه
نيفرسيسك الروسيه الواقعه على البحر
الاسود دون توضيح السبب
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها استهدفت
مواقع علي القوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه
كوبيانس بينما اعلنت قوات الشرق في الجيش
الروسي انها احبطت محاوله تعزيز وتبديل
عناصر للقوات الاوكرانيه على جبهه
اوروجينيه ونشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
صورا قالت انها لقوات المدفعيه اثناء
استهدافها منشات وبنيه تحتيه ومعدات
عسكريه اوكرانيه كما نشرت الوزاره صورا
انقلت انها الاستهداف القوات الاوكرانيه
اثناء محاولتها التقدم باتجاه
قبل ان يتم احباط العمليه
قال المتحدث باسمي قوات المركز في الجيش
الروسي الكسندر تشوك ان قوته صدى هجمات
للقوات الاوكرانيه في اتجاه
وقصفت مراكز ومواقع قياده ومراقبه كذلك
للقوات الاوكرانيه في مناطق عده
فحبطت وحدات متقدمه من مجموعه قوات المركز
6 محاولات هجوميه اوكرانيه في اتجاه
ايسباتوف وكريسنو لمان وبلغت خسائر العدو
اكثر من اربعين مسلحا وعددا من الاليات
وتم اسقاط ثلاث مسيرات اوكرانيه وقصفت
مسيرات اهدافا اوكرانيه وهي مركز قياده
ومراقبه ونقطتان بشار ومستودع ذخيره
المتحدث باسمي هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
اندريه الهجوم الذي نفذت القوه الروسيه في
اتجاه اورجينا في مقاطعه دونياتك بقى
بالفشل واكد ان القوات الاوكرانيه احبطت
كذلك محاولات تقدم روسيه في محيط مدينه
كوبيانز في مقاطع
الاوكرانيه الضغط على العدو جنوب ضخمه
ويتم تحسين مواقعها عند الحدود التي وصلت
اليها
ونفذ العدو عمليات هجوميه فاشله في مناطق
بمقاطعتي
القوات الروسيه خسائر كبيره في الافراد
والاسلحه كما تواصل القوات الاوكرانيه سد
تقدم الروسي في اتجاهات كوبيانس كوليمان
جميع محاولات المحتلين باءت بفشل والقتال
العنيف مستمر وشاهد خلال الساعات الماضيه
ثلاثه وثلاثين اشتباكا
في المقابل الثالث للقوات الاوكرانيه انها
شنت ضربات جويه على مواقع ومعدات عسكريه
روسيه كما قصفت ايضا منظومات صواريخ
للدفاع الجوي الروسيه ومستودعه الذخيره
ومحطه حرب الكترونيه